what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
we're back we're back everybody we're
back everyone back from the cruise and
it was all it was so fun if you want to
hear about like the whole cruise
experience I've got a vlogging channel
you'll find the link down in the
description I've already got a bunch of
videos there but I'll probably like tell
stories from the cruise like James in
the Puerto Ricans um dude it was like it
was a crazy story anyway I am refreshed
and I am back and I am ready to talk
about some stuff de totality let me tell
you guys something bout Scott Snyder
storytelling alright for those people
who are basically new to like DC
Universe rather they're kind of like
okay so I want to go read Justice League
it's basically Justice League number one
it's written by Scott Snyder here's the
important thing to bear in mind Scott
Snyder storytelling can be can be read
in one of two ways either it can be read
in isolation which is entirely possible
or it can be read cohesively and it
makes it all the better right like if
you really really wanted to appreciate
this whole thing in its full full
capacity I mean you could probably go
all the way back to like Grant
Morrison's Batman run basically like
when Batman died or in the events of
Final Crisis you can start with Final
Crisis and then go into Batman you know
like the return of Bruce Wayne and then
go into like Batman eternal and then go
into new 52 Batman run all the way up
through like death of the family and
Batman in game and all that kind of
stuff and then go into like Dark
Knight's Medal and then read this it
makes for like some epic a storytelling
it's just like one giant cohesive story
and that's why it's so cool because what
we know up to this point is that there
was basically this this item this this
object that was referred to as the
totality and nobody really knows what it
is but is essentially like this sort of
power of creation if someone manages to
harness it they'll basically be able to
kind of recreate the universe and the
reason why is because after the events
of Dark Knight's Medal are really during
the events of Dark Knights Medal this
led to cracks in the source wall and so
much like having a what you know having
like the hoover dam leaking water it's
only a matter of time before those leaks
turn into just like a massive explosion
of water forcing itself through and
that's what's happening with it with the
source wall the source wall is this
barrier around the multiverse and
basically it's dying and so when this
clock strikes down to zero whoever is in
possession of this this this totality
could potentially have the ability to
like recreate all of existence unto
themselves and so that's why it's really
kind of like a mad race for this thing
and so in this desire to harness this
this power Lex Luthor and the Joker had
basically stowed away in the bodies of
Superman and Martian Manhunter and
basically tasked with going in and
exploring the the whole idea of the
totality which led to Lex Luthor in the
Joker seizing control of them and then
trying to seize the power that of the
totality from themselves now of course
Batman and Hawkgirl were along for the
ride as guides not knowing Joker and Lex
Luthor was there which basically led to
Joker and Lex Luthor taking out Batman
and Hawkgirl and then just kind of
things unfolding from there so again
what we'll talk more about this as we go
through but still is a pretty cool thing
what we get here is basically Batman
popping back up after having believed to
have been killed by the cells of
Superman when his ship was destroyed and
he was left to you know sort of free
floating in Superman's body and Lex
Luthor's kind of astonished by the fact
that he's there now with Lex Luthor
facing off against Bruce this is not
something you normally see to see Lex
Luthor and Batman face off as cool
because this is really more of a battle
of wits Lex Luthor's not really a
fighter right he's not really like a
hand-to-hand fighter in the same
capacity as Batman but Lex Luthor I
would argue is smarter and so when
you're talking about these guys who are
sort of facing off it's a battle of wits
and that's why it works is because Lex
Luthor talks some incredible trash here
he basically tells Batman like you know
you're a child who's driven by
nightmares I'm a man driven by dreams I
will go on to achieve great things
because at the end of the day you live
and die by the memory of your parents I
live and die by greatness and so it's
just like damn Lex Luthor men talk is so
serious it's pretty cool now of course
this switches over to Barry Allen and
it's a really cool thing this is why I
say Scott Snyder writing Justice League
like this it's kind of bringing back a
lot of familiar things like the Legion
of Doom but the Legion of Doom had
always by and large just kind of been
this you know Superfriends hokey team
that was always defeated like well we'll
get you next time Justice League but
with Scott Snyder bringing them in to
Justice League like this in the the you
know the DC Universe run dude it it
elevates legion of Doom's just being
like powerhouses because having like all
these new into these new sources of
energy the sage force is still force
different things like that it allows
them to use them in a variety of
different ways where Barry Allen's speed
it's just move really really fast then
what happens if you take away his
ability to move and that's what this
still for duh I still forced does it
shuts down his ability to move his super
speed and he can't move at all well then
of what use is a flash that can't run
where you end up having like Barry Allen
being taunted by Gorilla Grodd all the
wild rods response is like it's amazing
that you were able to move like it's
cool that you're so in tune with the
Speed Force or at least what what passes
for the Speed Force now because it
doesn't really exist but it's cool
you're able to move so fast that you can
move about a centimeter or two
that's astonishing to me so like keep
running keep moving forward and in about
two centuries you'll finally reach the
door over there like it's it's so
awesome
now of course in response to Lex Luthor
being seized upon by Batman this leads
to him contacting the Joker who of
course is controlling Martian Manhunter
and then you know the Joker basically
using Martian Manhunter to attack
Superman so it's cool because you have
like these multiple layers here and so
of course this leads to Hawkgirl kind of
stepping up and then incapacitating the
Joker temporarily and then in turn by
the time this happens there's really not
much that can be done because of course
Lex Luthor has this doorknob now this
doorknob has been a very ambiguous thing
throughout the Justice League run by
Scott Snyder so forth we don't really
know what the purpose was it it served
but I found this interview that he did
and basically what he said is that this
is kind of like a a barometer that what
this doorknob does is it kind of gives
us an indication of how bad things are
right you know like like as this
doorknob glows with more and more energy
what it means is it like these other
forces out there are being harnessed and
so it's almost like once this thing
reaches a hundred percent then like
everybody's screwed and Anna's and it's
kind of cool here because it gives us
this little sort of stepping stone but
using the power of this these energy
sources that are out there Lex Luthor
catch Batman and Superman and Martian
Manhunter
right back to the Justice League
Watchtower basically boots them out and
he has he's basically in the presence of
the totality all by itself and so what
this does is this leads to a bit of
panic you have Lex Luthor who's who's
right over there in the totality we
don't have anybody who can stop him at
the same time you've got like um
barracks and these billions if not
trillions of ultraviolet lanterns all
bombarding the the Hall of Justice which
basically serves as a distraction which
is actually pretty smart we don't know
the full bore the full mind and the full
brunt of what they can do but we do know
they are exceedingly powerful and so in
response to this a cyborg
in Martian Manhunter and Jon Stewart
come over this idea that if humanity is
in this position whereby they're
basically being made to feel all their
worst emotions and all their worse
individual fears and all that in turn is
is giving way to like all this massive
amount of hate and like you know entropy
and so on which um Brock's is feeding on
and then in turn like trying to convert
the earth and like a giant ultra lantern
more or less then why not unite them in
that capacity like why not force people
to realize they're not the only ones who
have felt failure and different things
like that it is Jon Stewart and cyborgs
are really kind of counting on Martian
Manhunter to unite all the minds of
everybody across the
where you basically have like martian
manhunter reaching out to every single
superhero to every single human being
and basically saying all of us have all
felt fear and they all see the other
spheres they all see the others failures
it's not like they're they're kind of
operating unto themselves you know every
single human being across the face of
the world hero or otherwise fuels the
fears of every other single human being
and it basically unites them in a way
that hasn't really happened before and
so in this moment is kind of a funny
thing because what happens is it
basically kind of forces unblocks back
for a second in their United Minds
humanity comes to the realization that
they all are basically part of like a
singular consciousness that they all are
united under the banner of the desire to
be alive and in doing so the earth
itself is transformed into a white
Lantern and it's the craziest thing ever
craziest thing I ever saw a white
Lantern earth it is dude is so cool this
is why I say Scott Schneider is amazing
when it comes to writing this stuff and
so what you have is you have a United
Earth now what this does is it really
kind of seems to offer itself is like a
barrier for protection from um Brax
which really kind of prevents it from
going through and seizing a trouble
member this is them walking on a knife
set because you're talking about people
you're talking about an entire race of
beings who have never experienced single
consciousness before and so it could be
very easy for them to just kind of break
off and to fall back down to their
lessor sides which is the danger that's
being posed here and that's kind of the
back and forth that's going on between
humanity and like Sinestro now at the
same time that this is going on you've
also got Barry Allen here and it's kind
of cool because Barry Allen is focusing
on an on a role different from what he
normally does the role of a speedster is
to just move as fast as humanly possible
I guess as fast as any speedster can
move that's the basis of their character
but then suddenly you're thrust into a
situation where the flash can't run
super fast where the flash is gonna have
to run large patient have to slow
himself down almost infinitely like
every single cell every single atom in
his body is gonna have to be slowed down
to the point of non movement but it
works because what this means is that
this potentially allows either Scott
Schneider himself or a future writer to
come along use this concept of Barry
tapping into the still force and then
like granting in a whole new level of
power there's a lot of different things
that you could do with this you know
like like shutoff a speedsters power to
the to the Speed Force there's a lot of
things that you could do and it's super
cool because it opens up all these
different doors to all these different
abilities that that Barry as the flash
could have later
on down the line now while this is
happening they're also you know within
the Legion of Doom headquarters I'm
being bombarded by like you know Black
Manta and an cheetah and so on and so
forth I said where you've got Aquaman
and you've got Wonder Woman in there
coaxing Barry back into essentially
slowing himself down to tap into the
still force and basically shut off the
momentum of um Brax and kind of push it
back into its you know dimension for
lack of a better word you end up having
Aquaman breakout and of course he
basically ends up contacting you know
ends up talking like a whole bunch of
like sharks and stuff like that in order
to have them attack Black Manta to cease
their attack and then in turn like you
have Lex Luthor who's basically defeated
by a hot girl or at least in the in the
incident seems to be the case that he's
basically defeated by Hawkgirl but what
this does is it allows the Justice
League to win and it's crazy because
what is up happening here is that in
this moment with um Brock's being forced
out with this sort of these sort of
rifts being closed more or less then end
and in turn the entire conflict ends in
the blink of an eye because what it
means is that Barry's seen something
like Barry has basically seen the true
nature of the totality he's seen the
true nature of this power behind it all
and where he initially tries to shy away
Scott Steiner doesn't tell us exactly
what he saw now if we were you know if I
were a gambling man I would basically
say that Barry Allen saw the doctor
Manhattan was behind everything but he
was just a peek what he got was a look
through a keyhole
more or less and it's kind of crazy
because Scott Center kind of builds on
this and sank the Vandal Savage didn't
become a bad guy because it was just
kind of fun he became a bad guy out of
necessity because when this this
singularity I guess when this totality
was on its mission and eventually going
to crash in Anyang on earth in the
modern day it is sort of phased in and
out of time and so it meant that along
the way Vandal Savage had seen this this
totality and had gained a glimpse of
what it was about where the creation of
the multiverse came from and in
realizing that was terrified of what he
saw and basically became a villain to
ensure that nobody would be able to
access the power of this totality so
again a lot of ambiguity here a lot of
questions that are kind of being left
unanswered but it really kind of seems
to be Snyder pointing to the direction
of saying like Manhattan is the cause of
all this but it could be entirely wrong
so again we're really kind of grasping
at straws here there's no absolute
answers we're not really given any
visions we're just kind of given little
bits of clues here and there in little
bits of tidbits and different things
like that but of course this leads to
Lex Luthor being booted away from the
totality and a Hawkgirl being the one to
seize it for herself
and so in this moment she takes it back
to the Hall of Justice and that's what
ends up happening with the Justice
League as it Justice League basically
sits down you have Justice League dark
you've got the Justice League of America
you've got the Justice League team they
kind of sit down and they say our job is
to now analyze this thing but notice
this totality has kind of a blue aura
that's very reminiscent of dr. Manhattan
and so they're kind of like we're going
to analyze this thing we're going to
study this thing and we're gonna see
what this is about we're gonna gain
answers from it so that if we can you
know either we can use it to stop the
destruction of the multiverse or when
the multiverse dies we can kind of
recreate it and so again it's it's a
pretty dangerous game because this is
what the Justice League is continually
done and has only ever made things worse
and so in the face of defeat one is up
happening is that in the middle of all
this suddenly the entire Justice League
is met by the arrival of star Matt who
basically says look like I can show you
guys how to fix everything but that
means that like three of you are going
to have to die in the process now in
truth my experience on the character of
star man is not the most well versed but
if I were and you know again if I were a
betting man I would say this is probably
will Peyton that's who it looks to be Oh
will Peyton was a character who
originally appeared back in I wouldn't
say was on solo series back in like 1988
and in the post-crisis landscape anyway
he was struck by a satellite and
basically ended up you know gaining like
super speed and strength and durability
and you know he could fly but unless he
was an interesting character to see him
return here it's kind of intriguing
because I don't really know what role
he's going to play I mean of course it
really hits to the fact that like three
members of the Justice League are gonna
die over the course of the neck over the
course of what's happening and to me
that really seems to be an indication
that DC if I'm being honest DC kind of
seems to be like careening towards a
reboot is really kind of like it like
well not maybe not a reboot with
someone's like a reset we're gonna get
like the Doomsday Clock story and I
think this is gonna kind of like reset
everything sort of zero hour crisis in
time for the unit like the multiverse
blinks out of existence and then comes
back and suddenly everything's set back
to the way that is supposed to be before
a new 52 I'm not 100% sure again it's
really kind of a guessing game here but
but with regards to Lex Luthor himself
you know with regards to the two facing
defeat at the hands of the Justice
League this is amazing because Lex
Luthor realizes that what he needs is an
unstable element a bit of chaos because
when it comes to the to the the Legion
of Doom despite the fact that they are
heightened at the end of the day they
still are relatively predictable because
their powers are familiar to the Justice
League what they need is complete and
total chaos in unpredictable character
and so one is up happening is Lex Luthor
transitions down into the bowels of the
Legion of Doom and simply tell somebody
you were 100% right I need your help I
can't do this on the on on my own only
for us to find out the person who
talking to you is the Batman who laughs
so it's just like damn like it's pretty
badass guys so I am extremely excited to
find out where this ends up going I'm
pretty hyped about this but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
come this explain make sure you guys at
the sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]